the first Topic at a at a top 15 school
that is located in the heart of what you
might call Music City and I think we
know who we're talking about here the
colors are black and gold
um they um they basically said Anne
welcome
you are here for a tour we're so proud
of what we've done here there's a lot of
things going on here and one of the
first things we want to let you know is
how in we're not just inclusive we're
inclusive and also providing Services
you can get gender reassignment surgery
and support here at not our health
center but the hospital that's part of
the research yeah first question let me
ask you how many minutes before the
orientation started that message was
given that was within the first five
minutes tell me your joking Tom no I'm
not I'm no I'm not and I had a parent in
front of me turns her turns around and
looks at me and and she makes eye
content and under her breath you could
hear her say she didn't curse she was
like starting with this